[Musik]
in china gibt es neue corona infektionen
in der hauptstadt peking werden gebiete
abgeriegelt darunter ein großmarkt polen
öffnet die grenzen zur eu nach drei
monaten ist freies reisen auch von und
nach deutschland wieder möglich
schwere gewitter starkregen und hagel
nach dem schwül warmen sommerwetter
kommt die heftige abkühlung
[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
heute am samstag unserem
nachrichtenüberblick den sport hat
norbert lehmann dabei ganz schön guten
auto familie in peking hat sich das
corona virus zurückgemeldet und das
nachdem die sicherheitsvorkehrungen erst
kürzlich gelockert worden waren
denn offiziell hatte es in den letzten
wochen dort fast keine infektion mehr
gegeben
umso besorgniserregender der ausbruch
jetzt und zwar rund um einen großmarkt
das ganze viertel wird abgeregelt
strenge kontrollen quarantäne
der markt gilt als umschlagplatz für
lebensmittel die ganz peking versorgen
sollen
nach ersten tests sind bereits knapp 10
prozent der stichproben positiv
befürchtet wird aber viel mehr
stephanie schöneborn berichtet es sind
diese bilder die heute morgen china und
die menschen in peking aufgeschreckt
haben hundertschaften der militärpolizei
regeln einen der größten märkte pekings
ab auf dem großmarkt im südwesten der
stadt waren sechs mitarbeiter am corona
virus erkrankt massentests werden
durchgeführt
wir haben bei 1.940 personen die auf dem
großmarkt arbeiten einen corona
durchgeführt von 517 ausgewerteten
speichelproben wurden 45 positiv auf
cobit 19 getestet auf dem markt werden
neben gemüse vor allem fleisch und fisch
verkauft die meisten restaurants
kantinen und supermärkte in peking
beziehen ihre ware von diesem großmarkt
das virus sei auch auf einem
schneidebrett für importierten lachs
gefunden worden
fast zwei monate lang wurden in peking
keine neuen corona fälle registriert
gerade erst wurden die kontrollmaßnahmen
gelockert und die menschen haben nach
monaten der entbehrung so etwas wie ein
normales leben begonnen
jetzt sind viele verunsichert und haben
angst vor einer zweiten corona welle
die stadtregierung hat strikt reagiert
in elf viertel rund um den markt dürfen
die bewohner ihre wohnungen vorerst
nicht verlassen
einige provinzen warnen davor nach
peking zu reisen und viele bereiten sich
auf einen erneuten lockdown vor
ich habe angst dass ich mich infizieren
könnte und mein kind auch wir werden
versuchen nicht rauszugehen
es ist unmöglich in so kurzer zeit
dieses virus vollständig einzudämmen
die waren des plus marktes werden nun
entsorgt und neben der angst vor der
zweiten welle kommt jetzt die angst vor
all den entbehrungen und
wirtschaftlichen folgen des virus mit
sich bringt auch in brasilien entspannt
sich die lage nicht im gegenteil die
zahl der menschen die an den folgen des
corona virus gestorben sind stieg auf
fast 42.000 nur die usa beklagen mehr
todesfälle
besonders hoch ist die opferzahl im
bundesstaat sao paulo mehr als 10.000
menschen
insgesamt zählt brasilien fast 830.000
ansteckungen und obwohl die zahl der
neuinfektionen weiter hoch ist werden
die beschränkungen vielerorts gelockert
nach polen ins grenzgebiet zu
deutschland
hier haben sich viele auf den heutigen
tag gefreut markiert er doch das ende
des ausnahmezustands
wegen der korona pandemie hatte polen
die grenze zu allen eu nachbarn
geschlossen rund drei monate lang
jetzt gehen die schlagbäume wieder hoch
und auch der kleine grenzverkehr kann
wieder ungehindert fließen natalie
steger berichtet um mitternacht feiern
sie es gemeinsam polen öffnet seine
grids deutsche können wieder einreisen
das tut auch der oberbürgermeister von
frankfurt oder
er trifft seinen kollegen in der
nachbarstadt slubice emotionale momente
abstandsregeln kurz vergessen
ein wunderschöner tag für uns heute hier
um hat es glaub ich auch gemerkt haben
eigentlich vorgenommen nur mit den
ellenbogen aber es ging nicht anders
es geht wieder los im polnischen
grenzgebiet viele polnische
kleinunternehmer haben gelitten wie hier
in chinon goldene lebt man fast
ausschließlich von den deutschen kunden
günstiges essen günstigerer tabak ein
bus kommt an aus berlin nur gut 60
kilometer weg hier kann man so schön
einkaufen für dich erfahren von berlin
nur 230 einwohner und beachtlicher 36
friseur salons sowie der von agata buch
hat mit fünf angestellten schon am
vormittag brummt es wieder
ich bin sehr zufrieden dass wir staaten
können drei monate war unser salon 2
ohne deutsche kunden können wir nicht
existieren
restaurantbesitzer an jake musste vier
angestellte entlassen
er hat wie viele hier nicht verstanden
dass die nationalkonservative regierung
entfernen warschau die grenzen so lange
geschlossen hielt dieses virus hat doch
keine nationalität falls das virus in
deutschland wäre nicht aber in polen
wäre eine grenzschließung okay aber das
virus hat keine nationalität im
polnischen grenzgebiet hoffen sie nun
dass die pandemie nicht noch einmal
hochkocht denn eine zweite
grenzschließung würden viele hier
wirtschaftlich nicht verkraften
deutschland frankreich italien und die
niederlande haben sich zu einer im fall
jan zusammengeschlossen das ziel
gemeinsam will man erreichen dass ein
impfstoff gegen das virus für
alle bürger der eu verfügbar ist ein
erster vertrag wurde bereits
abgeschlossen über mindestens 300
millionen im stoßen mit astrazeneca das
britisch schwedische pharma unternehmen
hofft bis ende des jahres einen
impfstoff entwickelt als erstes
bundesland hat thüringen zu einem
kontakt beschränkungen wegen der korona
pandemie aufgehoben abstands und
hygieneregeln aber bleiben ebenso wie
die masken pflicht ansonsten gelten nur
noch empfehlungen ohne strafandrohungen
die nachbarländer bayern und hessen
reagierten mit kritik
brandenburg will hingegen nachziehen am
montag enden die kontakt beschränkungen
auch dort bei den aktuellen corona
zahlen für das ganze land wird deutlich
dass die neue infektion auf einem
niedrigen niveau bleiben im durchschnitt
der vergangenen sieben tage haben sich
täglich 330 menschen neu angesteckt
insgesamt registriert die johns hopkins
universität mehr als 187 1000 infizierte
davon gelten fast 172000 als genesen
8793 menschen sind in verbindung mit 19
gestorben
anderes thema sexueller missbrauch von
kindern ist eines der großen
gesellschaftlichen probleme dies hat der
jüngste fall in münster wieder gezeigt
die frage die sich dabei auf drängt wie
kann es gelingen kinder und jugendliche
besser zu schützen
eine antwort sucht nun auch die
katholische kirche im bistum limburg
betroffene wissenschaftler und
kirchenvertreter haben sich die fälle
dort genau angeschaut und eine strategie
entwickelt stefan schlosser gerade mal
zehn jahre war er alt als die qual
begann jahrelang wurde kai christian
moritz von einem katholischen priester
missbraucht als er endlich den mut fand
sich der kirche zu offenbaren traf auf
eine mauer des schweigens
es war klar da wird keine große
konsequenz daraus folgen also stand er
schnell im raum
es wird nichts bezahlt ja wenn damit an
die öffentlichkeit geht da wäre ich
einfach nur öffentlich gegrillt worden
dann hörte ich dass ich lüge oder
irgendwas hätten alles abgestritten
verschweigen vertuschen damit soll in
der katholischen kirche endlich schluss
sein
betroffene wissenschaftler und
kirchenvertreter haben in einem projekt
des bistums limburg vorschläge
erarbeitet wie sexueller missbrauch
künftig besser verhindert werden kann
das sind maßnahmen die sind nicht
unerheblich und wir wollen durch sehr
viele einzelmaßnahmen einfach einem
besseren miteinander und einem weniger
großen machtgefälle institutionelle art
in der kirche gerecht werden so soll
beispielsweise eine unabhängige
beschwerdestelle eingeführt werden
außerdem gleichberechtigung von männern
und frauen im ordinierten amt keine
diskriminierung von homosexualität mehr
eine neue form der priesterausbildung
und die opfer sollen im mittelpunkt
stehen
das wichtigste für das bistum ist es
diese kommunikation mit den betroffenen
umzukehren sie nicht ihnen nicht mehr
das gefühl zu vermitteln dass die
bittsteller sind wenn sie sich denn
überwunden haben sich mitzuteilen
sondern auf sie zuzugehen so weit ist es
noch lange nicht lisa scharnagl hat als
betroffener im projekt mitgearbeitet
sie wurde mit 14 jahren von einem lehrer
in einer schule des bistums missbraucht
den bischof hält sie für glaubwürdig
insgesamt sein verständnis und
transparenz in der kirche aber viel zu
gering
aber es gibt eben auch person in
leitungspositionen im ordinariat die das
ganze so nicht möchten oder eher
verhindern wollen
die katholische kirche macht schritte in
die richtige richtung findet auch kai
christian moritz doch vorschläge müssen
nun auch umgesetzt werden
weltweit gehen die proteste gegen
rassismus und polizeigewalt weiter und
immer wieder geraten denkmäler ins
visier der demonstranten in london wurde
zuletzt eine statue des früheren
premierministers winston churchill
beschmiert eine provokation für hunderte
britische nationalisten und
rechtsextremisten die sich heute an dem
monument versammelten
dabei kam es zu auseinandersetzungen mit
der polizei sie setzte auch tränengas
ein
in frankreich waren es tausende die
gegen polizeigewalt auf die straße
gingen
zu der kundgebung hatte eine frau
aufgerufen deren bruder 2016 bei einer
festnahme gestorben war
sie verglich sein fall mit dem
gewaltsamen tod von george freut auch
hier gab es jedoch zwischenfälle mit
rechten gegendemonstranten hagel und
unwetterartige regengüsse haben weite
teile nord und ostdeutschlands
heimgesucht und auch in den nächsten
stunden geht das wohl so weiter die
schweren gewitter kamen mit sturmböen
und führten örtlich auch zu
überflutungen
antoine kurschilgen gibt einen überblick
wassermassen wohin das auge reicht in
niedersachsen den landkreis goslar fällt
so viel regen in kurzer zeit das ganze
orte unter wasser stehen besonders
schlimm hat es den kleinen ort luther
erwischt hier steht das wasser bis zu
einem halben meter hoch keller laufen
voll und der strom fällt aus
ein bisschen gehört relativ weit weg
noch und dann hat so leicht angefangen
zurück und auf einmal sind alle dämme
gebrochen wie aus eimern hat es geregnet
dann der halter zugezogen wir zurzeit in
der ortslage das problem dass also wir
eine senke in der ortslage haben und
dort befindet sich in altenheim
was wir also versuchen zu schützen auch
bei salzgitter gibt es schwere unwetter
ein plötzlicher hagelschauer legt
zeitweise den verkehr auf der a 39 lahm
in lübeck werden zwei männer schwer
verletzt als sie schutz in dieser hütte
suchen die wenig später vom blitz
getroffen wird beide müssen im
krankenhaus behandelt werden und rund um
berlin regnete es so stark dass straßen
und keller unter wasser stehen eine
ziemlich ungewöhnliche wetterlagen muss
man sagen denn wir haben hier sehr
feuchte energiegeladene luft aus dem
osten bekommen und in der haben sich
diese krassen gewitter entwickelt und
mancherorts ist so viel wasser runter
gekommen wie gut in der anderthalb
wochen und das in eineinhalb stunden und
auf keinen fall sollte man noch auf den
letzten drücker sein auto aus der
tiefgarage retten wollen wenn es voll
gelaufen ist und auch unterführungen
können lebensgefährlich sein
und es bleibt ungemütlich auch im laufe
der nacht kann es unwetter und gewitter
geben warnt der deutsche wetterdienst
wo einst die berliner mauer verlief ist
nur noch an wenigen stellen in der
hauptstadt erkennbar
der abriss im großen stil begann heute
vor 30 jahren auch wenn viele
mauerspechte und andenken sammler schon
vorher mit dem abtragen der mauer
begonnen hatten
ab dem 13 juni 1990 rückten die ersten
bagger an
ein halbes jahr später ist fast nichts
mehr von der mauer zu sehen
roman leskovar manchmal stück hat sich
die natur erobert
viel ist in berlin nicht mehr da abseits
von gedenkstätte east side gallery
potsdamer platz der koloss der die stadt
einst teilte nur noch zu erahnen
zum verdruss vieler touristen erhalten
der anfang vom endgültigen ende startet
heute vor 30 jahren am 13 juni 90 beginn
des systematischen abrisses an der
bernauer straße
ab jetzt werden nicht nur straßen
verbunden das symbol der deutsch
deutschen teilung soll komplett
verschwinden
schon im dezember die innenstadt
weitgehend mauer frei west berlins
regierender bürgermeister zur wendezeit
erinnert sich gut an die stimmung damals
die ganz überwiegende meinung der
menschen war das muss weg ihr besonders
der berlinerinnen und der berliner
die wollten das ding einfach nicht mehr
sehen die hatten sagt und deshalb gab es
auch eigentlich keine ernsthafte
diskussionen darüber
einer der die berliner mauer maßgeblich
zerlegte wohnt bis heute im
oberpfälzischen weiden seien
jahrhundertauftrag festgehaltenen
artikeln und hobbyfilmer
tausende tonnen mauer schreddern seine
maschinen ihn wurmt der abriss aus einem
anderen grund sein beton endet als
straßen material während findige händler
kleinste brötchen als souvenirs
veräußern
das kaum hat die krise darauf an
zwischen drei und fünf mark und ihr habt
wie titanic 4000 die steine habe ich 21
das zweite hinterher ja im internet die
angebotspreise bis heute ordentlich laut
beschreibung gibt es dafür immerhin ein
komplettes mauersegment 1 hat sich auch
winfried bremen aufgehoben vor seinem
wohnhaus steht es und das soll auch so
bleiben
ja und nun zu dir norbert unserer
fußball bundesliga und da gibt es immer
noch keine vorzeitige entscheidung in
der meisterschaft allerdings hätte
dortmund das spiel in düsseldorf
verloren
dann hätten die bayern heute abend zu
hause mit einem sieg über gladbach alles
klar machen können aber der bvb der
gewann ganz knapp in der nachspielzeit
jede bisherigen ergebnisse des 31
spieltags düsseldorf und dortmund mit 0
2 1 wolfsburg und freiburg unentschieden
2 2
hertha verliert gegen frankfurt klar mit
1 zu 4 köln union berlin 1 zu 2 und
paderborn geht regelrecht unter gegen
bremen mit 1 zu 5 ein ganz wichtiger
sieg für werder im abstiegskampf
das abendspiel bayern gegen gladbach
bereits gestern hoffenheim bleibt sich
nur zu zwei die tabelle spitzenreiter
bayern kann heute abend seinen vorsprung
auf dortmund wieder auf sieben punkte
ausbauen
leipzig dritter dahinter gladbach
leverkusen und wolfsburg die zweite
tabellenhälfte beginnt mit herta und
hinten alles unverändert aber bremen als
siebzehnter jetzt punktgleich mit dem 16
düsseldorf paderborn abgeschlagen
schlusslicht
das abendspiel bayer gegen gladbach
bayern gegen gladbach ausführlich um 23
uhr im aktuellen sportstudio mit dunja
hayali neben der bundesliga ist
rassismus im profisport das top-thema zu
gast fußball nationalspieler benjamin
henrichs vom as monaco und die deutsche
basketball nationalspielerin set to the
belly von den dallas mavericks
zum basketball finalturnier der
bundesliga da hat bamberg mit dem ersten
sieg in der gruppe b seine chancen auf
den einzug in die playoff runde gewahrt
bamberg besiegte in roth frankfurt mit
99 zu 83 spielte dabei über weite
strecken souverän
die hessen müssen ihrerseits wieder um
das viertelfinale bangen
das am mittwoch beginnt autokinos sind
in corona zeiten ein sicherer ort nicht
nur um filme zu schauen sondern auch
live sport etwa stabhochsprung und so
fand der erste deutsche leichtathletik
wettkampf vor zuschauern seit ausbruch
der pandemie in einem autokino stadt
gestern abend in düsseldorf
das publikum begeistert von dem
extravaganten sportplatz angetan sind
auch die athleten und bog an der tabelle
den weltmeisterschafts vierteln das hat
auf jeden fall was also die locations
offenbar sehr schön hier auf dem
parkplatz und die fernsehen auf jeden
fall ganz nah dran und es hat einfach
eine piratenserie warnblinklicht zur
anfeuerung 230 autos 600 glückliche
besucher ich kann das rabental dass so
was überhaupt möglich ist torben blech
sieg mit übersprungenen 5 metern 55 vor
wäre die leistung nicht ganz so gut
wegen des windigen wetters aber alle
sind froh dass sie endlich wieder einen
wettkampf hatten schöne die schöne show
danke da war denn viele die in corona
zeiten geburtstag haben feiern anders
als sonst
auch die britische königin mit einer
deutlich kleineren parade als sonst und
nicht in london sondern auf schloss
windsor ohne royalen familienbesuch und
ohne den jubel tausender briten aber mit
nationalhymne und dem fest eingeplanten
sonnenschein wegen des wetters feiert
die queen ihren geburtstag traditionell
und obwohl sie schon im april 94 jahre
alt geworden ist und sich immer noch
toll hält das wetter bei uns nicht
gerade stabil auch über nacht folgen
weitere schwere gewitter zurzeit gibt es
aktuelle warnungen für baden württemberg
niedersachsen thüringen sachsen anhalt
und brandenburg genaueres zu unwettern
morgen weiß gleich besten terry so viele
von uns für heute danke für ihr
interesse
das heute journal am samstag mit claus
kleber sehen sie um zwei viertel 11 und
uns morgen wieder am abend um sieben bis
dahin ein schönes wochenende
[Musik]
einen schönen guten tag und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter eine ziemlich
energiegeladene luftmasse erreichte uns
heute aus dem osten und dementsprechend
gab es heftige gewitter es ging
ordentlich zur sache mit starkregen
großen regenmengen kurzer zeit ja und
das setzt sich teilweise in der nacht
fort dieses ringgebiet das wandert
langsam weiter nach westen und hier sind
dann starke gewitter eingelagert ganz im
süden kommt ein neues regengebiet auf
teilweise ebenfalls mit gewittern und da
müssen sie auch mit starkregen brechen
über längere zeit im osten der lok hat
schon wieder auf temperaturen sinken
dabei auf 12 grad am alpenrand und 18
grad an der ems morgen dann im
tagesverlauf wieder unwetter und zwar
vom emsland über das hessische bergland
richtung vogtland und hier teilweise
wieder starkregen hagel und sturmböen
die üblichen verdächtigen ganz im süden
regnet es weiter richtung ostsee lockert
es auf und es scheint sogar die sonne
für längere zeit und das bei
temperaturen von 26 grad im osten und 15
grad am alpenrand
die nächsten tage werden im süden eher
etwas durchwachsener seien mit regen bis
26 grad im norden sonnenschein
ja und dann zum mittwoch kommen wieder
gewitter auf damit ein schöner abend